hi my name is Jacob Abrams I'm a
director of engineering at Glu Mobile
i'm here to show you my android
application it's called bonsai blast
it's a simple game we have a couple
different modes survival and adventure
I'm going to show off survival here just
press the air to go into the game it's a
simple puzzle game it has many different
levels with the balls you've matched
three balls they explode and they don't
get any closer to the end when it gets
to the end it goes down the drain and
you lose so here I am I'm just matching
these three colors trying to keep the
balls and getting too close to the end
so i was just playing survival mode now
i'm going to switch over to our other
mode of venture mode just bring up the
pause menu click right here and withdraw
from this this mode i'm going to just go
right here into the other mode adventure
mode and so in this mode you get to
unlock all the different levels and
features that are available in bonsai
blast so we'll start out on this level 3
right here alright so the technique here
is to get as many points as you can and
fill up the bar over here at the top of
the screen so there got a big bonus
because i just unlocked a treasure chest
at this point I'm simply matching 3 i'm
trying to gain as many points as i can
so my company Glu Mobile we decided to
develop a game for android we picked a
game called bonsai blast to develop it
takes advantage of a lot of the features
that android has it has a touch screen
interface it has a high frame rate lots
of sound effects and it's a fun game to
play but it's a difficult game to master
so how we developed this game we
basically ported this game from j2me so
it's got a midlet class in a canvas just
like j2me but we switch that to an
activity which is like a midlet and a
view which is like a canvas that part
was pretty simple then we moved on to
working on things like CPU usage one of
the advantages of Android is that it has
a simple tick interface basically we
just use the ondraw method and to do our
threading we called invalidate in
gameplay to
increase the performance to the absolute
maximum when you're in a menu that has
animation we use post and validate delay
to slow down the frame rate but free up
the CPU so it's not killing the battery
because this is a mobile device when
you're in a non-static over near in a
static screen we use we turn off the
constant repainting so that the handsets
not draining the battery and we only
respond to user input and that way the
battery life is kept to an absolute
maximum while you're playing our game